they kept arriving all day
most of the african migrants reached
seota by swimming some two kilometers
along the coast of morocco
or on land passing a 10 meter high wall
which spain had erected
more than 8 000 people crossed the
border into the spanish enclave on
monday
a single day record spanish officials
said
spain deployed the army to patrol the
border and sent the migrants back to
morocco
soldiers did not shrink from using force
about half the people who arrived have
since been expelled back to morocco
spanish prime minister pedro sanchez
visited celta to show the government's
support
before the trip he made this statement
my priority as spain's prime minister at
this moment is to guarantee the control
of transit through the border with
morocco
provide the cities of sota and melia
with everything they need to resolve
the humanitarian crisis is a result of
the arrival of people
and to proceed with the immediate return
i repeat the immediate return of
everyone who has made an irregular
entrance to celta in milila
as stipulated in the agreements spain
and morocco have signed years ago
migrants from africa have been
attempting to get into europe via this
beach for years
but they have never crossed in such
numbers
some reports as well as this footage
suggest moroccan police allowed many of
the migrants to cross over to sota
unhindered
because of a diplomatic spat with spain
morocco is upset that a separatist
leader who is seeking independence for
the western sahara region ruled by
morocco
is currently getting medical treatment
in spain
officials in madrid say they are further
reinforcing security in sota
to prevent any further arrivals
let's learn more about this from juan
fernando lopez aguilar
he's a member of the european parliament
from the spanish group of the
progressive alliance of socialist and
democrats
he sits on the parliament's committee on
civil liberties justice and home affairs
welcome to dw um is this problem in
theater purely a spanish matter or
should the eu become involved
it is actually a european issue because
it happens that celta and lia
are the only terrestrial external border
of the european
union with the african continent more
than that
it's the more the most unequal
external border in the whole planet
there is nothing like it not between
mexico or the united states
not between south korea north korea the
most unequal
so it is an issue for the whole of the
european union
and it's not a migratory situation it's
a diplomatic situation with political
component elements
it's only obvious that these
youngsters including miners
have been launched by
moroccan police forces precisely to put
pressure on a situation which actually
puts a challenge
to the spanish handling of the external
border in the first place
but it also puts a challenge to the
whole european
union so again it's a situation in which
we have to claim
the binding solidarity and shared
responsibilities which are the
pillars of the european union when it
comes to an area of
reduction security so do you believe
then that the eu
should intervene on both counts on the
migration issue
and spain's rao with morocco and if so
what should brussels be doing
but of course but of course the
prime minister of spain has actually
asked for and obtained full support
from the leaders of the main european
institutions in the european
architecture including commission
the lion including vice president
skinass which is responsible for this
including commissioner johansson which
is the home
commissioner for migration and asylum
and security matters and including
the president of the european parliament
so yes
it is time to be aware that morocco
is a strategic neighbor
for the all of the european union it is
for spain for one thing
so they have expressed the european
authorities have expressed solidarity
with spain
fine what now should they do beyond
talk
well they have to support spain when it
comes to
all of the financial tools and funds
which are at disposal of a member state
which has a force major or
kind of a crisis situation an external
border of the european union
and we have put in place those
allocations the security internal
security fund
the asylum and migration fund
in order to provide for the assistance
and the social care which is needed for
the unaccompanied minors that have been
launched
through the sea because for the adults
there is always the possibility to
return because they are binding treaties
with morocco signed by spain and morocco
which are also compulsory to the other
part which is morocco so it is a matter
of putting all the political pressure
to get things right in place and back to
normal the sooner the better
thank you so much for joining us sir
juan fernando lopez aguilar a member of
the european parliament
thank you for having me let's cross over
to our correspondent nicole riss who's
in
madrid nicole tell us how things are
looking
this morning well after a very tense one
and a half days it seems that feyuta is
waking up to a much
calmer situation this morning this is
not only because the
spanish side has sent in special forces
to deal with the situation
there have also been talks in the
background diplomatic talks
and it now seems that the moroccan side
has started to control this border again
there are still a few intents to cross
it of course but it seems to be
manageable
in the meantime spain has announced that
they have at least returned
four thousands of the migrants that had
crossed uh back to
morocco they can do that because there
is a very um
old agreement between morocco and spain
that actually makes it
lawful to do these express returns many
thousands though are still also
in in accommodations right now emergency
accommodations this is uh particularly
also young people under 18 which are not
accompanied and also vulnerable groups
there needs to be a more thorough check
into their situation
and what will happen next to this um to
these people but as you can imagine
the normal uh reception centers that are
usually uh in the utah are overwhelmed
with the many people that are still
there so the next step will be uh to
look into what will happen
to them and they're also obviously
humanitarian aid
um there's also humanitarian aid on site
to look after these people okay so so
many have been returned and yet the fact
remains that thousands were able to
cross
the border to soto in the last couple of
days how
has that been possible
it's all been possible because the
moroccan side basically uh stop
controlling the crossings they usually
together with spain
look after this border this is a shared
responsibility
both sides look into this matter but
they have neglected
that and it's thought that this is due
to a diplomatic rope
and this border is quite strategic as
well it's not only
spain's most a southern border it's also
an external border of the eu
so uh in opening it this could just just
tackle another migration crisis and
morocco seems to know that
and they seem to have been outraged by
the diplomatic row and
they're using these migrants as
bargaining chips to show
what can happen when they just uh take
their uh border control off now you
mentioned a diplomatic
spat can you tell us a bit more about
how this whole situation was triggered
in the first place
well it's not that they have officially
admitted it but observers
think that this has to do with the
western sahara region
a region which had been annexed by
morocco in the 70s
and since then and many other years
spain and also other countries such as
germany have expressed that that would
support an independence of this region's
region and now this has always been a
thorn by morocco's side and just
recently spain
has taken in the leader of a group that
also fights for the independence of the
western sahara region
to give him medical support he's
actually recovering from
the coronavirus and that has sparked
outrage
on the moroccan side and it is thought
that this is what
led to this situation a display of power
that shows
what morocco could be capable of if
they're upset about something
dw correspondent nicole riss in madrid
thanks so much